hi there i'm the bob explained animated
and the scp we're taking a look at today
is scp-628
the unthinkable lizard
jimmy sat on a park bench looking pretty
happy with himself
as he was enjoying his lunch it was a
chipotle
when suddenly the lizard slithered up to
him
it was a pretty cool looking lizard with
blood dripping from his powerful jowls
it stood at a towering height of 5'1
had shiny scales and for some reason
wore a toupee scp-628 is known for being
pretty smart
and plays chess with semi-pros jimmy
looked very intimidated because he was a
wannabe chess player
and if he wanted to become a semi-pro he
would have to beat this huge lizard for
a shot
at the title for champion of chess the
lizard looked down on jimmy with a
poger's smug on his head
and said you can't beat me at chess
jimmy
you don't stand a chance i am the
unbeatable lizard
and i will prove it with this sick chess
move
jimmy looked scared but was pretending
to look okay
while jimmy was lying to himself the
unflinchable lizard leapt into the air
and did a 360 degree no-scope backflip
onto the chair behind him
and set up the chessboard with one fell
swoop
jimmy started to cry as he had never
been this scared before
the lizard was cool though and just sat
with his back to jimmy
and waited for jimmy to sit down jimmy
being very slow on the uptake just stood
there crying
628 said bruh i sent this chessboard for
us to play chess hurry up
ffs jimmy snivelled and said oh okay i
thought you were just flexing on me and
i had a chest date with a really good
semi-pro or something my mistake
no problem 628 said jimmy shuffled up to
the table wiping the slabber away from
his mouth
and eyeballs and face and regained his
composure
jimmy sat down at the table to play
chess but there was a question he'd
always wanted to ask the unforgettable
lizard so
he decided to ask it listen man i gotta
ask you this question
sorry if it seems rude but why do you
wear a wig
lizards don't have hair it really
confused me when i seen you for the
first time
for a minute it looked like 628 was
going to ignore jimmy
but it turned out he was very
self-conscious about his wig
and a single tear dropped out of one of
his eyes the one beside his ear
jimmy it's a wick okay i have always
wanted to have a really nice haircut
like all the rest of you
i think i turned to chess when my lack
of hair made me sad
but when i wear this wig i feel more
like myself
isn't that what life is all about being
yourself
jimmy was stunned as he didn't think the
unquenchable lizard was such a complex
emotional monster you know 628 you've
really taught me something today
and yes you are right you always should
be yourself no matter what but
you shouldn't kill farmers they're just
doing their job
you kind of screwed the pooch on that
one wouldn't you say
the lizard stared at jimmy and started
slowly smiling
then they both burst into a huge fit of
laughter and it was funny
jimmy i hate it when people laugh at my
hair and sometimes i get carried away
you're right but i'm trying to be a
better person now
the lizard said with a caring tone in
his voice this little talk put jimmy at
ease
as it made him feel sympathy for the
murderer in front of him
you sure are one crazy lizard mr 628
i feel like you're just misunderstood
the lizard must have lost itself in the
conversation
because its mood changed quickly to
focus on the task at hand
okay enough chit-chat boy said the
lizard
now we must play chess and you will see
how
powerful i really am a bead of sweat
trickled down jimmy's brow this was it
there was no backing out
the undefeatable lizard made the first
move as he was the white side
he was confident ten minutes later a lot
of chess had happened
and they were both very angry 628 was
getting bored and not really paying
attention
as he was so powerful at chess that
jimmy was just a pawn to him
but suddenly jimmy surprised the
unbelievable lizard
with a move he called the acid bath
gambit
to his shock this made 628 spring back
into action and checkmate jimmy in only
two moves
it seems that this was part of the
lizard's anomalous plan
that was disgusting the lizard said
really loudly it almost sounded like a
lion roar
jimmy looked frozen like a statue the
ungrateful lizard looked like he was
going to punch jimmy
and leapt at a very fast speed towards
him a small bit of pee
leaked from jimmy but he stood his
ground as he was feeling
confident after almost beating someone
in chess which is something he had never
done before
but instead of punching him on the face
the lizard hugged jimmy
you are the first person to have ever
came close to beating me in chess
and for that you deserve a treat enjoy
this hug
and a 20 off voucher to chipotle when
you spend over 30 dollars
jimmy looked at the lizard with those
type of eyes that anime characters have
when they see their senpai or something
oh my god thank you this is so nice
you know i would have never thought a
lizard as scary as you could be so
generous and nice
thank you i love chipotle too how did
you know
the lizard started slithering away but
before he went back from once he came he
said
that's my secret jimmy i am always
learning about new things every day
because i am the unmistakable lizard
and winked then he went back to his
shift at the chipotle
jimmy's mouth was as big as a harbor and
he just stared for a while feeling full
as he had already finished his chipotle
and didn't feel like spending 30 dollars
right now
his mind was blown oh and the object
class is ketter too
and that is the unplayable lizard thank
you for watching the bob explained
animated
and don't forget to like comment and
subscribe next week we'll be peeping
scp-490
the bird healer catch you in the next
one
[Music]
april fools so this video was intended
to be
lighthearted banter i have a great deal
of respect for
all of the current and future animation
channels
please don't misinterpret this video as
anything more than a light-hearted joke
actually in trying to create the abysmal
animation of this video
i find even more respect and admiration
for the animators
i think i'll stick to what i do best
thanks for watching
and a normal video will be this weekend
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
suser hintern zarguran
onyx arbiter soul
the morrigan retalias
karim el ashmuy the alpha walrus
patrick bailey dreams
matthew gilmore eric corbage
kawaii fire keeper joker corvus
king madding james saba
and nj vojak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogue thank you
you